Donald Trump held a huge rally this weekend.
To what?
Yes, he lost the election.
Yes, there's a raging pandemic with record
cases and deaths.
And yes, Trump's rally in Georgia had a huge
crowd, huge crowd, very few masks, and went
almost into a third hour of Trump ranting.
And Trump is still insisting he won the election.
The rally, hilariously was ostensibly to support
the two Republican Senate candidates running
in Georgia.
Trump devoted about 20 minutes of the nearly
three hours to them.
He's just too self-centered and narcissistic
to make it about them.
And you've got to see this to believe it.
As I mentioned, this was almost Fidel Castro.
Like in nature, Trump almost went into a third
hour in Valdosta, Georgia, ranting about whatever
crossed his mind.
And the upside is this will end soon.
He is only president.
Six and a half more weeks, my friend.
So let's dove directly into it because we
have a lot to get to.
Trump kicking off the rally with the lie that
he won the state of Georgia.
Thank you very much and thank you, Melania.
And I want to say hello, Georgia.
We did a great job.
You know, we won Georgia, just so you understand.
So Trump, of course, lost Georgia.
Joe Biden won Georgia, and as scary as it
is that a president still says this, a full
month after an election, it's scarier that
a crowd of thousands is cheering it.
That's really the scary part.
Hilariously, Trump almost admitted that he
lost, but then he backpedaled, realizing he
was about to implicitly concede.
Take a look at this.
I think they say that if you win Florida and
if you win Ohio in history, you've never lost
an election.
This is got to be a first time.
But the truth is, they were right.
We've never lost an election.
We're winning this election.
And and, of course, again, the fact that people
cheer for these lies is horrifying.
Trump wasn't just declaring nonexistent victories
electorally.
He also declared victory in the Christmas
war, the war on Christmas, a fake, phony,
nonexistent war out hardworking American patriots.
Let me begin by wishing you all a very merry
Christmas.
Remember the word?
No, we started five years ago and I said,
you're going to be saying Christmas again.
We say it proudly again, although they'll
they'll be trying to take that word again
out of the vocabulary.
We're not going to let them do that.
That war doesn't exist.
Neither did the war on Thanksgiving that he
talked about just weeks ago.
And then Donald Trump falsely claimed that
a lot of people are already vaccinated from
covid.
That was weird.
And let me also express our warmest, best
wishes and love to all of those people and
families suffering from the covid pandemic.
Vaccines are on their way at a level that
nobody ever thought possible or would have
taken another administration five years.
It took us seven months.
And they're starting next week.
And we're going to start vaccinating.
And a lot of people already are vaccinated.
It's called you have you caught it and you're
immune.
Now, of course, nobody's been vaccinated other
than the people that were part of the clinical
trials for the vaccines.
Trump, I guess, meant people who got the virus
and recovered are immune.
Just as a reminder, we don't know how long
immunity from recovered patients lasts.
It's unclear whether you are immune longer.
If you had a more serious case of the virus
versus an asymptomatic case, is an example
very dangerous for Trump to be spreading this
type of stuff when we have a raging pandemic?
Another incredible moment was Trump telling
people to vote for Kelly Lefler and David
Perdue in the upcoming Senate runoffs while
in the same breath saying it's completely
rigged, which, as we talked about earlier,
might actually convince people not to vote.
Or a state has had this prominence on the
Senate races because it never together.
And this is something that's very important.
And you have to get out.
You have to vote.
You have to make sure you have every vote
counted, every vote has to count.
You got to make sure they don't throw away
any ballots.
You got to make sure that when they collect
the ballots and they start bragging about
how many ballots they already have, you got
to make sure your secretary of state knows
what the hell he's doing.
And you got to make sure your governor gets
a lot tougher than he's been.
He's got to get a lot tougher.
You really should vote, but it's rigged.
Trump also attacking the Georgia governor,
Brian Kemp, and the Georgia secretary of state,
Brad Raffensperger, just out of this world
lunacy at this rally.
Then Trump pulled out the C word.
No, not that one that you might imagine he
would use about Kamala Harris.
This is communism, about Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris.
Of course, there's not a single communistic
idea in Joe Biden's platform, not a single
socialist idea in the campaign, nor in the
incoming administration.
So far, these people want to go further than
socialism.
They want to go into a communistic form of
government.
And I have no doubt.
Somehow that doesn't suit Georgia too well,
that's not true.
Now, of course, if you go up to anybody at
that rally and you say, yes, good evening,
sir or ma'am, which Biden policies are communistic,
ask them what communism even is.
It will get very embarrassing very quickly.
But they're continuing to harp on this meme,
which, by the way, the meme might have won
Georgia, Florida for Trump.
It's conceivable that Florida went that way
because that the socialism meme worked on
Cuban-Americans in Florida.
So I'm not pretending it doesn't work.
I'm just telling you it's bonkers.
And then a completely Kafka esque moment when
Trump read from printed out sheets of paper
that have so called irrefutable facts about
the election.
Take a look at this thing or a rigged election.
There's no way it could have happened.
You know, it's it's interesting.
I wrote this and I had just a few of the facts,
which I think because I want to get onto the
presidential I want to I want to stay on presidential,
but I got to get to these two because they're
great.
But listen to this.
These are the facts.
And each fact is like irrefutable.
And it means when President Trump received
one by one of the most brilliant political
people, President Trump received more votes
than any previous incumbent president in history.
Our lost our.
So we received more votes than anybody in
history, any incumbent in history.
We lost supposedly we didn't lose.
We're going to you're going to see the no
incumbent who received 75 percent of the total
primary vote lost reelection in the history
of our country.
Every single one of these, of course, has
a but Trump received more votes than any previous
incumbent, but still millions of fewer votes
than Joe Biden.
An incumbent with 75 percent of the primary
vote has never previously lost.
But there really wasn't a Republican primary
this year because of the pandemic.
And the number is not causal.
It's a correlational number.
In any case, the entire night was like this
again and again and just literally hours of
it.
Trump still then after, you know, he ranted
for two hours and then still hasn't figured
out that the election is over.
Listen to this one.
And they want to hurt it very badly.
And if these two don't get in or if I don't
get into these, we got to get the best would
be all three.
Nothing will happen.
Oh, then there's a hilarious moment where
Trump is talking about who knows what at a
rally supposedly from Georgia for Georgia
Senate candidates, these are just non sequitur
rantings.
I don't know what he's talking about here.
Like to say it came from Europe.
No, actually, well, specifically, it came
from Italy.
Italy saying, what did we do?
This wage war on American energy, absolutely
decimating Georgia's middle class.
Well, your bills will go up.
Not a huge energy producer, but Texas.
Remember, they said Trump will lose Texas
by a lot.
I said, wait a minute, I'm in favor of energy.
I'm the one that built.
We have the greatest energy we've ever had.
That is Trump rallying in support of Georgia
Senate candidates.
Imagine what he would be doing if he was trying
to hurt them rather than help.
And then Trump claims to have won Wisconsin,
which he lost so much.
And we knew that before.
But it's like they said, Wisconsin.
A poll came out Washington Post, ABC just
before the election.
I'm going to lose Wisconsin by 17 points.
I said, no, I'm going to win Wisconsin.
Well, actually, I want Wisconsin.
They're trying to say he's a little down,
but I actually won.
And then one more bizarre moment.
Donald Trump talking about the vegetables
he likes blueberries, peppers, squash and
cucumbers who grow does cucumbers around here
because I like cucumbers.
Can you I'm the only one I like.
You got absolute, absolute last one.
Trump wrongly telling people they really need
to vote on June 5th.
The election is actually on January 5th.
But everything that we've achieved together
is on the line on June 5th.
So this is funny.
And, you know, to see the the delusional,
petulant child who still can't admit he lost,
but it is really, really dangerous.
This is corrosive to democracy.
This is a global embarrassment.
And this also has the potential to be stochastic
terrorism.
Trump is railing against poll workers, against
the secretary of state, against governors,
against Democrats, against Biden, saying he
stole it, they stole it.
It's all stolen.
This actually can inspire people to violence.
And we've already seen people inspired by
these rantings to start harassing and going
after poll workers in Georgia and even other
states.
So this has a very real world component.
It's not just corrosive to democracy ideologically.
It also actually could inspire real violence
against people.
And again, just a few more weeks of this,
just a few more weeks of this.
Let's take a quick break.
We will be back with very much more in just
mere moments.